With Taskmaster set to step into the upcoming
Black Widow movie, it's time to dive into
a long history that's strange even by the
standards of the Marvel Universe.
From a school for supervillains to the South
American village populated by Hitler clones,
here's the truth behind the Taskmaster.
The Taskmaster made his first appearance in
1980's Avengers #195, arriving on the last
page to set up his full appearance in the
next issue.
Created by David Michelinie and George Pérez,
his entire identity was built around one simple
idea: Anything you can do, he can do just
like you can.
The Taskmaster's power is usually referred
to as "photographic reflexes," which is a
fancy way of saying that if he sees someone
doing something, he can replicate that action
exactly, and he keeps that skill for the rest
of his life.
That would be a pretty impressive ability
in the real world, but Taskmaster lives in
the Marvel Universe.
He can settle in with some footage of Spider-Man
or Black Panther, and hop off the couch a
few hours later with the ability to perfectly
replicate their movements.
Of course, there's one interesting limit to
all this: photographic reflexes are Taskmaster's
only power.
That means that while he can watch Captain
America throwing his shield or Iron Fist doing
kung fu, he can only replicate the movements.
He doesn't have the Super Soldier Serum-enhanced
strength behind the throw or the ability to
channel the power of an immortal dragon into
his hand.
The same goes for more mundane abilities,
too.
While he can spend all day watching Wolverine,
he's never going to have an adamantium -coated
skeleton.
Still, he's come away from his battles against
the Avengers with some pretty impressive abilities.
While he's done his share of hands-on villainy,
the Taskmaster's true calling has always been
education.
Of course, Taskmaster's version of education
isn't all that selfless, especially when you
consider that his "school," the Taskmaster
Academy, is less of a learning institution
and more of a for-profit training center for
henchmen.
For a low price, Taskmaster takes on classes
of aspiring supervillains, and teaches them
how to not only fight like superheroes, but
more importantly, how to fight against them.
There's no better way to prepare for fighting
Captain America than by training with a guy
who can fight exactly like Captain America.
While this mostly functions as a pretty amazing
explanation for where all the masked members
of Hydra and AIM get the confidence to try
to punch out Iron Man or whomever, it's worth
noting that it's not just the bad guys who've
taken advantage of the Taskmaster's skills.
Taskmaster was also responsible for training
John Walker, better known as U.S. Agent, during
the latter's brief stint as Captain America,
and for training government superhero recruits
in Avengers: The Initiative.
"We're working...
Class dismissed."
Like Deadpool, the Taskmaster made his living
as a super-powered mercenary for hire when
he wasn't running henchman classes, meaning
that the two characters ran in pretty similar
circles.
While their first encounter didn't exactly
end on the best of terms, they'd end up encountering
each other pretty often, and that eventually
led to a friendship.
One of the Taskmaster's most prominent roles
in the comics came when he was a member of
Deadpool's supporting cast.
His frequent appearances were mostly due to
the fact that Deadpool hired Taskmaster's
ex-girlfriend, Sandi Brandenberg, to be his
secretary.
But when Deadpool blew up, lost his memory,
changed his codename to Agent X, and was then
revealed to have not been Deadpool all along,
Taskmaster helped to re-train him as an assassin
and later fought alongside him.
In more recent years, the two mercenaries
have had a more back-and-forth frenemy relationship.
They've occasionally come to blows while on
opposite sides of a conflict, but Deadpool
was also willing to help Taskmaster out by
going easy on him in a fight so that Taskmaster
could still get paid.
He even invited Taskmaster to his bachelor
party!
Taskmaster's status as a sort of utility player
of the supervillain world has led to more
than a few minor roles in projects outside
of comics.
The most prominent one, at least until Black
Widow hits theaters in 2020, has been his
presence in 2018's Spider-Man for PlayStation
4.
In the game, the Taskmaster occasionally shows
up to challenge Spider-Man, but he does so
in a way that suits how his character works
in the comics.
Rather than confronting him directly at first,
Taskmaster puts Spidey through a series of
challenges.
Presumably, he does this so that he can get
a good look at Spidey in battle, which leads
to the fight where he actually does show up,
doing a pretty passable impression of Spider-Man's
own moves.
"If you know…
If you can."
While he's mostly shown up as a villain or
a supporting character, the Taskmaster has
dabbled in being a protagonist in his own
right thanks to two self-titled miniseries.
The first is a relatively straightforward
action adventure, but his second miniseries
is full-on bananas.
The main premise is that the Taskmaster, ironically
enough, has a memory problem.
His brain is so loaded up with superhero moves
that his muscle memory has overwritten other,
less important things, like his past.
In order to keep himself centered, he has
to keep tracking down his own memories, following
his history so that he can piece it together
and figure out who he is.
It's sort of like Memento, only a million
times weirder.
The path to Taskmaster's memories leads him
through things like an encounter with Don
of the Dead, a Latin-American drug dealer
who turns out to be a white American S.H.I.E.L.D.
agent who'd taken the "Don of the Dead" identity
after Taskmaster trained him.
That, however, pales in comparison to where
that series ends up: Wewelsburg II, a small
town in the Bolivian Andes where Nazi scientists
escaped to after World War II in order to
continue their experiments cloning Hitler.
The most successful result was the long-time
Marvel villain the Hate-Monger, but the scientists
wound up with a gigantic stockpile of cloned
Hitler-brains, which leaked the Fürher's
"bio-chemical essence" into the local water
supply.
The result?
Every man, woman, and child in the town essentially
has Hitler's brain, leading to a constant
warfare among themselves for control of the
town.
Beyond Wewelsburg II and the Don of the Dead,
the big reveal of the Taskmaster series is
that it finally gives us the Taskmaster's
origin and his real name.
That was what he'd forgotten, the piece of
knowledge that sent him on that bizarre quest,
and the answers change almost everything.
For years, the Taskmaster had been getting
his orders from a secret organization called
"the Org."
But as it turns out, the Org doesn't exist.
Instead, it's the wife that Taskmaster doesn't
remember having, Mercedes Merced, who was
also his partner back when he was a S.H.I.E.L.D.
agent named Tony Masters.
As Nick Fury tells Steve Rogers, the Taskmaster
has been a good guy all along.
He just doesn't remember it
As Masters, he was sent to infiltrate the
supervillain community for S.H.I.E.L.D., using
his powers and creating the Taskmaster identity
as his cover.
Unfortunately, thanks to a flawed prototype
of the Super Soldier Serum that expanded his
powers, all of those skills he'd absorbed
overwrote the personal parts of his memory.
Mercedes has been minimizing the damage for
years by creating the Org, acting as Taskmaster's
handler, and pointing him in the right directions
for S.H.I.E.L.D.
Of course, once he discovers all this, he
immediately has to absorb yet another sequence
of physical actions, forgetting the revelations
about Tony Masters and putting a heartbroken
Mercedes right back into the role of working
with a husband who doesn't remember she exists.
While it's doubtful that the Don of the Dead
or the Taskmaster Academy's acclaimed henchman
resource program will make it into the MCU,
it's not difficult to imagine how Taskmaster's
presence could be felt in the upcoming Black
Widow movie.
Most of Natasha Romanoff's history has to
do with her training in the Red Room, a secret
Soviet program designed to create a series
of highly trained agents who are given the
codename of Black Widow.
In addition to being briefly shown in Avengers:
Age of Ultron, the Red Room also produced
Peggy Carter's nemesis, Dottie Underwood,
on the Agent Carter TV show.
With the Taskmaster's history of training
supervillains, and his ability to serve as
the perfect teacher in virtually any style
of combat, it's easy to picture him as one
of Natasha's trainers.
Even more than the visual, the Black Widow
version of the Taskmaster captures the character's
signature abilities with an accuracy that's
really exciting, both for longtime comics
readers and the MCU fans who have never picked
up a comic in their lives.
Moviegoers have seen these characters in action
for over a decade, and whether they realize
it or not, they've seen how those movies distinguish
their characters in ways that go beyond their
costumes.
Captain America, Black Panther, and the Winter
Soldier, for instance, all essentially have
the same set of superpowers but they each
have a fighting style that doesn't look like
the others.
You're not going to see Black Panther deliver
that one sternum-shattering Muay Thai kick
like Cap does, and you're not going to see
Bucky Barnes pull off the same acrobatic attacks
that T'Challa busts out, either.
You will, however, see the Taskmaster do it
all.
In the Black Widow trailer alone, we see him
perfectly mimicking Captain America throwing
his shield, Hawkeye's draw with his bow, and
Black Panther's claws, among other moves.
What's more, Black Widow seems to be making
an effort to not just copy the style, but
to mimic specific moments from earlier films.
The shot with his claws in particular bears
a striking resemblance to a shot from the
war sequence in Avengers: Infinity War.
Much like the way that the comic book Taskmaster
ran his school for aspiring supervillains,
the cinematic version has also embraced his
calling as a teacher.
This time, he's the guy running the Red Room,
the top-secret Russian training facility that
produces the super-spies of the Black Widow
program.
As a result, he's someone that our most familiar
Black Widow, Natasha Romanoff, knows from
her past.
He's also apparently responsible for training
Yelena Belova, the second Black Widow in the
comics who initially set out to eliminate
and replace Natasha long after the original's
defection to S.H.I.E.L.D.
The fact that it's the Taskmaster, however,
adds another layer to the story of Black Widow
returning to the Red Room with the intention
of taking it down.
Not only does the Taskmaster's ability to
replicate any movement that he sees make him
the perfect combat instructor, it also hints
at something that might just be the true purpose
of the modern MCU Red Room.
Outside of a brief, hallucinatory flashback
in Avengers: Age of Ultron, we never really
see much of what Natasha's training was like
in the MCU, and what we do see seems like
some pretty standard stuff.
The fact that Taskmaster can fight like the
Avengers, though, might just mean that this
resurrected Red Room isn't just training its
soldiers to take on enemy spies.
In the comics, the thing that makes training
with the Taskmaster such an alluring prospect
is that if you're sparring with a guy who
fights exactly like Captain America, then
you might just figure out how to beat Captain
America.
If that sounds like a long shot, consider
that Cap and the Winter Soldier, the product
of a similar, Red Room-adjacent program, laid
a beatdown on Iron Man that was about as devastating
as the one Thanos did.
If the Red Room is turning out soldiers designed
specifically to take down superheroes, then
there's a very good reason why Natasha would
want to take them down that goes well beyond
revenge and atoning for her own dark past.
We'll just have to wait and see if the Taskstudent
can defeat the Taskmaster.
"Look around…
The day their heroes failed them."
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.